foreign
hello and welcome to the view from 22.
my name is Lisa and I am joined today by
my colleagues felana morinet who joins
us from Ukraine where she is reporting
for us for the next few weeks
today we are discussing the attack on
the Kirch Bridge which occurred this
morning in the early hours and is
thought to have been the result of a
drone attack as a result of the attack
this morning a section of the road
bridge has been damaged reportedly
although the railway line remains intact
joins me now from Kiev
what's the view on the attack on the
Kirch Bridge from Ukraine
first Ukrainian government never
recognizes any attack on Crimea they
always say we don't know who made it but
it's pretty obvious that Russia didn't
destroy their breach Ukrainian media
site in their resources have reported
that the attack on the bridge was made
by a special operation it was a special
operation but the security service of
Ukraine Ukrainian intelligence and the
naval forces
and allegedly the breach was attacked
using surface drones
and
it's important to remember that last
years announced a project to create a
fleet of marine drones in Ukraine and
then he said it was to protect the grain
deal and a Ukraine's borders
but as we could see yesterday these
drones were used to attack the the
sevastopol the Russian flea Fleet in
sevastopol and also last night the
Carriage Bridge so that fundraising was
really successful
the strones they're very expensive and
Ukraine don't have my doesn't have much
of them only they were raising money to
buy 100 of them because one costs about
200 000 pounds and ukrainians were
donating to buy those trans people from
from abroad and finally we could see
them in work
does that mean that the drones that were
used definitely did come from a stock
supplied by the Ukrainian military or
the Ukrainian
um
yes or from the Ukrainian secret service
all their sources say that it was like
that I mean we will know only when the
war ends and we will find out all the
secrets but uh yesterday in social media
there were there was a footage of a
damage drawn in the sea and it was
identified as a Ukrainian surface drone
that was used to attack Russian Black
Sea Fleet so this time about the attack
on Carriage Bridge it could be the same
and also the blast happened below the
span possibly at one of the piers and so
it was not made from the above
so why do you think it's so rare for
Ukraine to claim responsibility for
um incidents such as this uh to be
honest I don't know why they don't
recognize that they did it probably they
wait to see you for the reaction of our
allies what they say about that but I'm
sure that these attacks are discussed
before they actually happen with Ukraine
allies because it's important that we
don't cross those lines that they talk
about but Ukrainian government has been
repeating constantly that they're gonna
use Ukrainian weapons to strike Russia
for example or to liberate Crimea but
they're not gonna use like Western
weapons but it wasn't quite true also
because they were using Storm Shadow
missiles
so I don't know I don't know why they do
it
thank you and um are you able to tell us
a little bit about what is so important
about this bridge why is it that it's
so significant for both Ukraine and for
Russia
for Ukraine to damage the bridge is only
not like a military point but also a
political and psychological uh to solve
Russia that are they are capable of
doing it and also to give some pressure
for Russian population in Crimea because
right now for they can flee the
peninsula only on ferry but when the
weather is windy the fires don't go so
the only options is through the occupied
Mainland and it's very dangerous because
there is like an ongoing fighting and
in Ukraine there are a lot of dogs that
when the question comes to the
liberation of Crimea that Ukrainian Army
we just destroyed the Carriage Bridge
and be waiting in the entrance of Crimea
because Russian army will have nowhere
to go and so that brings me on to my
next question as well which is what sort
of significance do you think the attack
on the catch bridge last night has on
the Ukrainian counter-offensive do you
think that this will have a particular
impact on how the Ukrainian
um military is then able to conduct the
counter-offensive
of course it won't help Ukrainian Army
to cross 250 kilometers of minefields
minefields but it will stop for some
time the trucks with weapons that were
used to bring more weapons to the front
line but also their Railway
Bridge wasn't destroyed and it is
important because many weapons
especially heavy weapons like tanks they
are transported by the railway
mostly that's why
there is there won't be a big difference
and the bridge will likely be repaired
in one month
so the day when they destroy it
completely then there will be no Railway
Bridge no like pedestrian bridge for the
bridge for the cars then then it will be
a significant but right now no uh they
need it or more drones or missiles a lot
of missiles to damage because it's quite
a big structure
and so what do you think then
says about the state of Russian defenses
sort of around Crimea particularly
around the Kirch Bridge
um is it a case then that the Ukrainian
military
is getting through very weak Russian
defenses or that the Russian defenses
are strong and Ukraine needs to do more
to penetrate those defenses acronym has
been claiming that Carriage British is
one of the most protected places in
Russia and it doesn't seem to look like
it is true
so I wouldn't say this is a Target
because there are Russian Airy defenses
in that area in Crimea and every day
they report about shooting down the
drones and the missiles we don't know
how much of that is true how much they
really shut down or they were at least
if there were these attacks we don't
know that we can confirm that
information but and they were using the
training with this Fork around the
bridge so ukrainians couldn't see where
to shoot but we see the results that the
bridge is quite reachable for Ukrainian
Army it's just just a question of
sources that Ukrainian Army has because
if even to say about that project it's
lensky was talking about about 100
Naval drones it is still so few so
ukrainians have to choose when is the
best time to strike the bridge
and so do you think it was worth it
Ukraine attempting to strike the bridge
now I mean the casualties in the bridge
would seem to have been a civilian
couple with um their daughter their
parents that has been reported have been
killed and the daughter's in Hospital of
course the bridge is a military Target
because it was illegally built after
Crimea was annexed and if Ukraine was
waiting that there were no civilians on
the bridge at the moment they would
never shut it because there are all the
time civilians and unfortunately this
war cannot be won without those price
prices that we have to pay and of course
it's sad that civilians have to suffer
but there is no other way to win the war
and but
you as we could see Ukrainian tactics
during their full-scale Invasion that
they try to do all the best not not to
kill civilians just to fight with the
Army but
it's you never know you're currently in
Ukraine and Reporting from Ukraine for
the next several weeks um I was just
wondering what's it how does it feel to
be back home and uh what has changed
about Kiev since you were last there
several months ago now
uh of course I'm so happy to be back
home and
for me it's the best place in the world
like for every Ukrainian a lot of things
have changed uh for me the most
significant difference difference is the
prices how much they inflated like they
tripled in this Supermarket by grocery
stores and unfortunately it's not the
case for the salaries and so it's very
difficult for people who earn less
especially especially for those who are
all there and getting pensions and
they're very low in Ukraine so I'm
wondering how they are survive surviving
here you know also
aerate and the explosions if there are
drone attacks or missile attacks I mean
people got used to it and it's
unfortunate because people shouldn't get
used to live in a worse state
but we have what we have what we have
but and also I see a lot of military on
the streets a lot of patriotic
advertisement to join the Army
and
in the city center on the maidan Square
they're um
a lot of little Flags they stay in the
ground with the names of their fallen
soldiers it's like now a small ritual
here in Ukraine if you have uh if you
lost a loved one in the war you write a
name and put a little flag and now the
square is full of those little Flags
there are like thousands of them and
it's really very sad
yeah that sounds like it would be
very moving to see
but still
cave is like the most protected place in
Ukraine because here is our government
and the most our intelligence everyone
so and it feels like you can see parties
in the evenings and people try to keep
living their lives but the farther you
go to the east the less you see of that
and you see more the more impacts on on
the life of ukrainians I will tell you
more when I go there
thank you so much that Lana
and thank you so much to all of you for
watching you can sign up to svetlana's
newsletter for free at spectator.co.uk
forward slash Ukraine foreign
[Music]